[Applause]
and tonight we're going to get right to
our top story a stunning and shocking
turn of events in the hunter Biden Saga
tonight early this morning a federal
judge refused to act as a rubber stamp
for Biden's weaponized Department of
Justice and put the brakes on Hunter's
sweetheart plea deal at least for now
now the U.S District Judge Mary Ellen
narica is her name questioned the
legality of the plea agreement and
wanted to know if Hunter was under an
active investigation for other crimes
like Fair violations and other Financial
issues which really he was in trouble
until they let the statute of
limitations run out as it turns out
according to prosecutors Hunter Remains
the subject of at least one ongoing
criminal probe and could be charged with
future crimes now apparently Hunter's
attorneys were under the impression that
this deal would grant their client full
immunity from any future charges they
believed that their sweetheart deal slap
on the wrist deal consisting of two
minor misdemeanor tax violations and the
Deferred gun charge would wipe his
sleigh clean by the way when the judge
asked the prosecution and the defense
could you have any precedence for this
type of deal on the on the gun issue
they couldn't cite a single case now why
do I have a hard time believing this
very important critical point that they
came to agreement on was not fully
vetted and agreed to before today's
court appearance why does something here
reek of a major LIE there's nobody
that's going to convince me they didn't
have a full agreement they were not
going to give any more future charges to
Hunter Biden and I think it was this
judge that saw right through it and
called them out on it then the judge
allowed them to try and hammer out a
final last minute deal but without that
provision there was no way Hunter's
attorneys were going to allow him to do
that that the judge refused to accept
the agreement Hunter pleaded not guilty
to the tax and gun charges and if found
guilty now Hunter could face real time
behind bars like the rest of America
unless of course another sweetheart deal
is reached now keep in mind according to
the Washington examiner this is the same
judge that sentenced another individual
the five years in prison for an illegal
possession of a firearm in the
furtherance of a drug crime in the
meantime the judge ordered Hunter Biden
to actively seek employment and barred
him from possessing a firearm
prohibiting from using alcohol or any
illegal drugs and required him to submit
to random drug testing and uh oh yeah
according to Federal prosecutors Hunter
could also be charged in the future with
a variety of other crimes including not
registering as a foreign agent as
Pharaoh requires so are we to believe
that Hunter's attorneys they didn't know
about all this until today or did they
have an understanding with a weaponized
and politicized Merrick Garland
Department of Justice that if you take
this sweetheart deal no more charges
will be forthcoming this does not meet
the smell test to me now this all comes
one day after judge naraco accused a
member of Hunter Biden's legal team this
was an odd Turner of events late last
night of pretending to be a staffer for
Republican Congressman Jason Smith on
the house ways a Means Committee on a
phone call to try and get a court filing
that was put in the case by the Ways and
Means Committee at Amicus brief removed
from the docket now Congressman Smith
who serves on that committee as chairman
previously submitted this filing asking
the judge to consider new evidence
against hunter from the two
whistleblowers who recently testified
very incredibly on Capitol Hill now
chairman Smith chairman Comer chairman
Jordan will all join us in a minute uh
but of course the Biden legal team says
this is all big one big misunderstanding
really on such an important deal point
we're to believe that I don't believe it
just like misunderstanding surrounding
Hunter's sale of uh his art his paint by
numbers remember the White House had
promised that Hunters paint by numbers
portraits of a crackhead
would not be connected to the
administration in any way they vowed
that no one not Hunter not the White
House not anyone would know who shelled
out the massive amount you're cracking
me up ma'am the massive amounts of money
for this amateur art as it turns out we
now know the identities of two of the
buyers including a wealthy Democratic
donor who President Biden oh magically
uh recently appointed to a prestigious
position in the administration another
Biden another buyer was a hunter
so-called sugar brother Kevin Morris uh
who helped Hunter pay off some of his
back taxes and even bought Hunter a
brand new car and evidently you know one
can get special access to the bidens if
the price is right just make sure to
check out you know to Hunter and check
in with him that the big guy likes to
keep up with appearances so the big
question tonight is what will happen to
Hunter but more importantly what will
happen to Joe Biden as a result of
everything we're learning and everything
we know after everything we learned from
the IRS whistleblowers including the
government's obstruction of witnesses
the lack of interest and censorship of
Hunter's laptop the doj stall tactics
that allowed the statute of limitations
to expire on serious tax charges lot
large amounts of money and how the FBI
of course tipped off Hunter about the
irs's quote plan surprise questioning of
him uh how can anyone involved be
trusted by anybody in the American
public hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else